you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on leeches
org and I'm going to play a 15-2 game
against well I see 46 all right
hmm let's go with the night f3 yeah
let's see what black comes up with
uh-huh c5 all right well let's shoot for
d5 grab some space it's going to get
sharp e 6c 400 d5 all right hmm
how to treat this that's a very early b5
my first thought is a for another is to
maybe play C 4 and after takes Knight c3
mm I think I like the idea of c4 because
on a4 there's Bishop b7 and I could take
the b-pawn but then they take the D pawn
mmm-hmm I'm gonna go with
let's go with this if they take they're
kind of in a way wasting some time I may
be I may be able to conveniently pick
this pond back up B takes Knight takes
excuse me B takes Knight c3 preparing
efore and then development with capture
so let's see how breton black approaches
this they they may play Bishop b7
waiting for Knight c3 and then give my
knight a kick I think on Bishop b7 I
think this maybe transposing to one of
the first standard games I've posted the
channel here I think a4 is a move yeah I
think I think we're arriving at a
similar position by transposition so I'm
thinking a four here to resolve to kind
of force this pawn to make a decision
finally I'll be fine which takes like
this strong control here so a4 takes and
then Knight c3 I want a little more
information about this pawn I don't want
to allow Knight c3 and then be kicked if
here before then I could go here and do
this kind of stuff so I'm thinking a e4
I'm gonna go with a 4 let's see will
they try and maintain their pawn on B
capture or push I have to make one of
those decisions I am okay I was just
going to say I'm really weakening my b5
square so they could have considered a
plan like taking keeping the square open
in other words in doing something like
85 and then sinking the knight in to be
4 so how to assess this position so far
in the Queen side it's pretty much
closed many instances of fixed pawns and
I think the the way forward now is b3
Bishop b2 the only thing I'm questioning
now is move order I like that this
Bishop is kind of biting on a rock and
I'd like to keep him just like that
so I need to anticipate ecigs
I want to be in a position to play e4 to
maintain that pawn with a pond so that
said I believe I play Knight d2 b 3 and
then Bishop to b2 because I'm expecting
them to go at g6 Bishop here I'm just
trying to work out how exactly to set up
my minor pieces here something other
than 9 2 d2 to support efore I don't see
it I don't think declaring my Queens
intention so early like c2 that's a good
idea
so and I don't think bringing my Bishop
out here is a good idea I think it's
important to play in the long diagonal
so after all that I'm going to go with
Queen Knight to D to e 4 well we'll see
what black does on e6 I'll be playing e4
I'm not sure where he's going to go one
of these two kind of makes sense I
believe to play to d3 I'm not fearing
any pin against my knight
oops any pin against my knight and I
think I'd be useful to have some support
over my Evie pond okay well I think I
know where he belongs so I should
probably run in for that as soon as
possible
there may be a little check I need to be
on the lookout for when my Bishop son be
too anticipating the dark square bishop
supposing one another he is unprotected
on b2 and may be tactically vulnerable
once black is castled and has their
Bishop protected there might be
something like Knight takes and on
Bishop takes Bishop Knight takes here
and then here with check if I'm castled
maybe that's going a bit too far you
know and it's just completely wrong but
uh okay well I think I could at least
start with this yeah let's go with b3 he
knows his place oh no I'm seriously
weakening c3 one thing I do not want to
have to deal with is a night landing
there yeah okay so let's get on this
diagonal and I could play e4 so this is
the situation I'm talking about
unprotected but he's also unprotected so
it's more of an issue once he is castled
and defended efore let's push in the
center there's no tricks like takes
takes and the knight jumping you like in
here to attack my queen because my
bishop can return to creek capture hmm
okay um you know what I'm gonna give us
a little bit more thought to my decision
with my light-square bishop now I'll
know what my second move is going to be
just castles I may may want to sidestep
something like this where the knight can
arrive on e5 with tempo against a piece
maybe it's better placed here
hmm maybe I have another thing to
consider like Queen here is its
queenside castling is that something
I could consider oh it is locked on the
queenside but it's kind of a little too
Airy these guys have drifted a little
bit too far away from where my king's
residence would be yeah don't really
like that idea I like that I'm playing
with this space advantage playing
against this bishop mmm I think in the
end I'm going to go for I'm gonna go
with the bishop here this might be an
idea to maneuver you know it might be an
idea so castles can I castle castles
castles Knight takes e5 takes Bishop
Knight takes Knight Bishop takes rook
Knight takes Knight with check in the
end they will have exchanged they will
have taken three of my minor pieces and
I and a pawn so 10 points whereas I
would have taken six a two minor pieces
and a rook so I'm fine with that
they'd be giving up the exchange in
getting a pawn for it if they go in for
this idea after I Castle yeah I'd be
fine with that
they're still playing with a piece
that's out of play I could just rule out
any tricky stuff against my Bishop next
with a nice developing move Queen to c2
reinforcing e4 a way forward might be
this rook over here and then playing f4
e five will see what black does about
their EEP on will they consider playing
e6 and e4 e5 these this is a really big
decision if it's completely locked this
would be the next pawn break okay that's
a little bit surprising and I guess
they're kind of lining up something like
this with the pond push hmm is it
worthwhile to stop this maneuver
airplane would have space disadvantage
this would make it a bit more
uncomfortable for them to pivot about on
the e5 square hmm suppose Queen c2
Knight g4 Bishop takes Bishop King takes
yeah Queen c2 Knight g4 Bishop takes
Bishop King takes I could quickly occupy
this long diagonal I like that idea
let's check um I don't think I have to
invest to move a 3 so let's just develop
let's also secure a loose piece here b2
and prepare to do similar if they're if
they're going with rook a to e8 I could
kind of make that nice offsetting type
of move you occupy the e-file I get in
position occupy the e-file it's not yet
open but we're preparing some type of
opening if this pawn it plays to e6 and
there's ever a capture I think that that
will just favor me I have two pretty
interesting ways to recapture I could
consider taking just like this and
playing on the e-file and you know this
pawn is without potential if this push
occurs and there's a capture and I'm
taking like this this pawn does have
potential to move but I have strong
control over it with pieces night there
and a bishop there are nice in such a
situation where the e pawn is exchange
for my D pawn and I'm taking like this
having the C 4 square open I'd really
like to have light square Bishop sixth a
pair of nice exchanged and actually both
the Knights exchanged and then end up
with actually I said that wrong I'd like
to have in such a situation where I have
my knight on c4 the light square Bishop
sixth
one pair of Knights exchanged and my
dark square Bishop exchanged for their
other night essentially a strong night
on this light square versus a dark
square bishop although this square could
be quite good for the dark square bishop
but anyhow what is black lining up here
ecigs or e5 should I just play rook 81
uh-huh yeah I think so so let's see how
things move forward here what will
blacks decision be it's kind of up to
him what he wants to do I'm more of an a
reacting posture here let's see let's
see what you're gonna do it your Yvonne
right here and give me an hour never a
moment to capture or will you give me a
while do you create immediate tension
with e6
I'm not quite sure I know I must be the
side who stands a bit better due to this
space advantage in this Bishop being out
of play this might be an idea as well
for black to not yet commit this pawn
and instead reroute the poorly placed
bishop under develop it but yeah come
out along this diagonal maybe and then
we'll see I think this is a useful next
move for me it stops Knight g4 and it
may also hmm you know what I didn't
consider this move into f4 okay he's
going with E 5 this was a bad move
now it's too locked you know what I
would have liked to have done
91 in 2d 3 I didn't hmm this was me this
was a poor decision because now my
bishops kind of doing similar to their
light-square bishop if I allow this pawn
to stay and if I take hmm okay should I
capture if we don't capture this will be
the idea
hmm I'm thinking about rook to d1 now
you here to here hmm if we're up to D
one night H 591 I think I'd want to play
g3 first rookie one night h5 g3 i-5 is
hitting really fast although it can't be
played right away because of this move
they have to play h6 first they have to
take some care over east six hmm liking
my decision to play my rook here this is
a very important decision to in the game
hmm well I don't want to capture the
pawn takes rook takes there's gonna be
some serious pressure against this guy
and I'm not in a good position to let's
say occupy the d5 square I'd be the one
drawback of recapturing with the rook is
that d5 is weakened but I'm so far off
from really putting that to use and I
feel like it's just and be target
practice for me in fact this night could
think about that stuff if he's no longer
around to pivot on c6
don't like my last moves just my
decision there move 13 I didn't really
evaluate this move here properly I
should have gone here I've wasted a lot
of time without I should have better
anticipated e5 and been prepared with
this maneuver 91 to d3 Knight h5 I
pretty much have to stop Knight f4 one
thing that's nice is that when I do play
g3 it stops the knight from playing to
f4 and when I do move my knight to e1
I'm throwing a punch at their night he
only has one safe Square to go to
current position all these backward
moves are illegal these moves are just
no good okay he has g4 but I'm not sure
what that really does mm-hm yeah and
they unlike their I could just
immediately that do that okay so there I
guess preparing 9 to h7 yeah this is
about to blow up
okay Knight go there they're gonna play
Knight h7 yeah I think this is gonna get
really really wild although you know an
f5 f4 is gonna hit and my bishop will be
freed once they set okay so they're
lining up what are they preparing this
hmm well let's get my knight here yeah
on f5 f4 you see this this move f4 will
bring this bishop his presence will be
felt a bit more as soon as I challenge
the e5 pawn with my pawn there's already
a knight and Bishop hitting here mm-hm
I may soon play rook here so yeah I've
made how many moves with that rook rook
e1 d1 back to e1 mm okay there it is
to play this right now well I do this
preparing to meet fi with F for let's
open this up and see what happens yeah
if this pawn ever takes this is another
route into e6 so h6 was to stop this but
there are there are there's a couple
pivot squares I can make use of to get
to the e6 square so on f5 f4 I don't
have to fear this you have to fear that
I don't think so either because I could
take and it takes here he's unprotected
on e4 I should just do this move let's
get there he's kind of not doing a good
job nor as the light-square bishop his
pawn on d5 is a strong one I think I'm
the better side here they've got better
pieces my minor piece is my Knights are
in better spots if we do a night for
Knight comparison I think my nights are
better
I didn't prove further if they do like a
nothing move like a five would I take
take like this I don't want to be so
quick to give the d6 square up to this
night you know here takes I have a
passed pawn but this is a this nidal
come right into d6 so I mean I don't
want to be so quick to take on e5 can I
improve my position further with let's
say Knight here or Bishop there okay I
don't have I'll kind of like seeing this
row because don't have much choice
sometimes it's good not to have many
options to consider uh yeah
let's take here indirectly defended by
Queen and rook so on takes in this
discovered attack that's fine I'm taking
like this or maybe first taking here
actually and then taking here it may
turn out I have to work around a black
knight on the e5 square for a little bit
but if that does turn out to be the case
he's under control at least by my Bishop
money
to have to worry about like Knight g4 or
something
also they have a more vulnerable King
yeah they have their to their G and H
pawns are in their their third rank so a
little bit airy this pawn is unprotected
they're looking to reroute now maybe I
can consider here huh
I think that'll help them out so I do
that should i reposition this guy mm-hmm
not sure what to do here
pawn takes I really don't want to do
that and it feels like there should be
some tactic here man Bishop f3 dropping
upon Bishop g4 Knight f6 yeah they can't
play Knight f6 so quickly and the knight
f6 Bishop takes well if this Knight is
free to capture I think my queen can
maybe sweep in okay we're gonna have a
bunch of exchanges let's I'm gonna try
for this let me consider just a little
bit more under three
Bishop g4 Knight f6 Knight takes bishop
takes they need to keep the peace on
this square Bishop takes Queen takes
pawn takes Knight takes Knight takes I'm
on this yeah this should be good then
he's a loose piece but that's alright
alright so Knight moves they go there
yeah
they don't move the knight I'm playing
Bishop to e6 and that's going to be
extremely uncomfortable because then I'm
ready to really crash through take a
bunch of times I was saying about being
a hesitant taking on this square cuz I
don't want to be so quick to give this
Square up but things have opened up a
bit and there are always these timely
more concrete lines you always have to
be considering is now the moment to do
it we're gonna see you're playing with a
knight on the first rank a knight on a
second rank I like my nights when we
compare those guys these will soon
probably just be gone this is a
desirable trade as well if we consider
good versus bad bishops situations you
know I mean one idea could be to check
and then maybe even push out five and
then play where I have a super strong
knight on e4 maybe one that I could just
reinforce we'll see there under six okay
what other move is there I'm only
looking at this move here I didn't
consider any other candidate moves for
black are they gonna consider capturing
here I still like this I know I don't
think that that could be good I mean my
knight jumping in here that would be bad
and that would that would be a very
difficult piece to cope with I mean bad
enough that you're losing upon but even
if you weren't losing upon a knight on
that square monster town I think I don't
know that you can allow this bishop to
play here
going here he's kind of going into
no-man's land
he's it's kind of under developing he's
not going on the back rank but it's as
if he's v6 is just as good as the back
rank it would it would seem
it seems to me okay so I'm not sure what
other moves to consider I'm really
thinking they're gonna play Knight to f6
and my choices will be quite limited I
think I'll take here first okay King
there mmm okay well they're on the same
diagonal so this is maybe something hmm
maybe you could move there huh I just
play here first or do I do this I was
think nice talking about this earlier I
do push here don't I f5 is strong hmm
give up on this capture or just push hmm
I'm gonna push let's see I could always
take with check if they push that's some
scary stuff going on there I have a lot
of clearance ideas push takes takes with
Czech Knight takes here discovered check
a lot of pieces in between the Queen and
King but I have I'm still I'm looking at
this diagonal for sure I think they need
to take I don't think they could push
and I don't think allowing me to take
and invite their king forward it's good
so many pieces on board how many I mean
we only have a pawn exchange at this
point whoa
they really did play that move that
cannot be right
not be right don't believe it that's got
to be correct yes I think they're
running right into these discoveries now
I get to move him and then I get to pick
my favorite square to go to with my
night as a discovery no this might be
even close to mate somehow functioning
on the g6 square checks light square
pressure yeah
Oh in another thing you know I could
take this and then here so this hmm I'm
thinking I'm thinking I can move this
night with it discovery eventually but
it's really this night where would be a
good discovery move okay so take their
Bishop first then take their night and
take their night that's Chuck see how
they recapture like that okay so hmm
okay I think I see the winning
continuation yeah my nights gonna get to
this Square
let's take care first then I get to play
this with check and play here with check
or mmm maybe I'm off with that because
they could take on e one first oh but
wait I don't have to take this pawn I
could play Knight here into here as
tempting as this move is here King here
I'm not landing a fork now though there
is no fork when I get there hmm
I'm down upon I want to play on the
light squares though Knight takes pawn
mmm-hmm I'm gonna go with this I think
mmm
yeah I'm not gonna take the pawn I'm
just gonna sink into this square I don't
know I kind of felt that my night would
be stranded there so let's try this play
on the light squares a little bit Queen
here here could soften up their Kings
side okay they're just taking it giving
it right back okay hmm okay they're
gonna hunt that pawn down let's see
that's two pawns and the minor piece for
the rook I'm already I'm already
wondering if I should have grabbed the
pawn regret already are you regretting
things already
um I guess here I can't hang on to that
pond anymore yeah my bishops having a
tough day mm-hmm oh yeah I gotta go fast
I don't know here yeah this was not good
I should have grabbed a pond I should
have given that a bit more should have
considered that more okay
let's get my king up a little bit I'd
like to have the rooks come up and take
care of her this f4 square it's a block
visit there's not enough open files for
me I don't know I'll go here there's an
open file it spawns pin No oh man okay
well maybe I could enter no the Bishop's
gonna play there let's see I got to take
that night out Bishop f6 I guess let's
see I'm gonna push and then target oh I
didn't even realize they have that move
oh that was silly and even conceived
consider that that night could head over
to a5 okay unfortunately they don't have
this cuz I could take their Bishop you
know I think I need to walk my king over
here rook up to I don't know one of
these I need to change roles I don't
want my rook tied down to defending b3
okay he's maybe a target okay King do
some damage
that Knight is so dangerous okay I could
get this guy now no scary I mean night
in here if they take with the C pawn
they have to connected pastors I have to
make sure they don't get rolling if I
take here I'm on there bishop mm-hmm
they're gonna get that beep on oh boy I
gotta go for some activity now I can't
save that beep on well I could track
down there a pond and then have a past a
pond myself this has gotten way too wild
where's their night going actually cuz I
could take here you can't go to a
okay they're going right into a pin
let's take that guy with check for
starters and I need to start generating
some threats of my own about that pusher
a pawn buddy
push that a pawn I think I could work
around a knight for a little bit here
he's kind of boxed out with my rook on
f2 let's see this might be a new sixth
rank a lot of pieces here huh
a lot interesting possibility so maybe
not so quick to push here and now you
have a passed pawn you get pushing that
guy there also caught up on time which
is nice see how they play under pressure
alright Bishop there let's keep pushing
put the pressure on there King is cut
off who's gonna stop my a pawn who's
gonna be the one they're running a long
time oh they just lost on time hmm I
think this position is winning for me
but Wow too scary too much hmm yeah I
gave too much counter play this night
getting out of control
my idea of functioning on the light
square is not giving not taking the pawn
back and instead of trying to come up
with some plan of playing on the light
squares yeah that really didn't pan out
so well yeah this is certainly something
to look back on I don't like my decision
to play here I wonder if I could have
immediately done this Knight reposition
without waiting for the e pawn to move
I'm not sure about that we'll check it
out with the computer and I don't know
how useful the computer will be in this
lock position eventually we get to this
point now I know the computer will be
very useful
no that has opened up and I'm pretty
sure I am the better side here let me
just click into the analysis board
yeah I probably should have taken that
pawn and then jumped into g6 for some
reason I was thinking the Queen was
going to take and then I would have a
fork against the rooks they took with
the rook dose and though sidestepping
that fork so let's just get a feel for
how the evaluation went here so it likes
oh my goodness there's an you're it was
+5 after g5 I missed some knockout man
you know after their g5 move I missed
some move sequence that should have just
ended the game and they were slightly
better then I was back to better and
then yeah they were they were better at
about pawn and a half around when I
played rook to e3 and then in the end
I'm just winning but Wow
okay so let's kind of fast-forward to
this middle game mm maybe not all right
around here
rook there you know you see this is an
uncomfortable position for black you
should go back just a little bit more
because you know the why am I going back
a little bit more let me explain the
computer at this point is suggesting h5
or rook here like these are nothing
moves these are like passing moves so
basically this idea to push here is I
guess just never good because I get to
reply with f4 a lot of tension pawns
will be exchanged and it still remains
that the bishop on b7 is just out of
play
and my pieces will be quicker to make
use of the side of the board which will
be open which is the king side so if FIF
is no good black has to basically sit
and wait and that's definitely not fun
not a good position to be and so how
could black have maybe done something
better a little bit earlier
I please see for Bishop there a4 is it's
definitely a move queen 85 very computer
like just pushed hmm yeah I mean the
alternative is well this was the one
other idea yeah this was the this was
the plan Knight c3 d4 and then here and
even if it's defended I could just take
it still although it's suggesting
something like e5 but I still can take
here if I wanted to because I have this
idea after to pick him back up but
anyhow this was my idea with the c4 move
and also a for kind of forcing black to
make a decision here the other one I
just want to look up look at just a
little bit
suppose they tried to hold ground here I
take I take the rook force them to
retreat and recapture and then simply
develop and suppose B 409 to b5 okay so
that's nice with the eight pawns no
longer on board I can play this Knight
c3 move and when kicked move forward
compare this with playing let's say
Knight c3 right now on b4 I don't have
this move because then that gets trapped
so that's interesting
so a 4 and I a 4 a 6 takes takes they
don't have an a pawn in fact let me back
up one moment as soon as this capture
occurs b5 is now a whole in the black
position and it's one that I could look
to hop to on the b4 move okay noted so
well what could black have done a little
bit different on c4 hey four
like this move any for ya it really puts
a question to this b5 idea he's uh Benko
like calling it the pseudo Benko Indian
came pseudo Benko on there right there
yeah I like this idea it's a bit of a
positional line I believe resolve the
tension in the center or not on the
center but make the b-pawn flinch make a
decision okay
b3 holds it as even get all our pieces
out and we're preparing for play on the
kingside computer is pushing for a 5 mm
hmm don't know about that
that kind of what's my reasoning with
this I see it as I you know a5 will be
met with a six and then he can't go out
for the a file now mmm I don't know
about that I'm not sure about a 5d one
okay well it likes my move rook to eat
rip to d1 now okay you know one thing
that must be said is even though I lost
time with this rook a 1 D 1 and then D 1
and then back to e 1 is it's a closed
position so time is not that big of a
factor it's not like it's a wide open
position and I'm just doing a little
shuffle there in a knight reposition
this is very locked
and so yeah time not not as big a factor
Knight h5 here has it as even Knight h5
Bishop takes King takes this was some
idea to get on the diagonal right away
came back g3 yeah I like my position is
right here
I like this Queen's post I like that
they no longer have their most important
minor piece for defense of their king
okay so there might be something tied in
with the dark squares especially if this
pawn moves f6 is then a whole something
that I could maybe look to exploit in
any case I believe it's it's white who's
trying to pick their way to its white
who's trying to show in what way they
are better okay so we did not have the
dark square Bishop six change a five
rook d1 and yes let's just consider this
is the big this was the big moment in
the game it does not like the idea to
capture because of rook takes and he is
getting hit a real lot the e pawn that
likes black why that move I guess to
stop this it also did pop-up h6 age six
h3 rook here and then I have to be
concerned about this stuff as well yeah
I mean I was saying it during the game
you know when this e six move is played
taking like this if they take with the
rook this is a hole in the black
position but it's not one I could make
use of you know I can't how do I get a
night here it's just so far off so can't
take advantage of the the weakness black
has in the position meanwhile black is
exerting seems like nice free pressure
against my epon don't like that so I'm
glad I did not decide to capture but
instead play it where my pawn was still
this this pawn structure was still
killing their light square bishop had
away sometime I'm repositioning now this
is a strong strong square for the knight
pressure here facilitates f4 in some
cases you'll also see if this b-pawn was
still in his home square a knight on d3
is also useful for playing a b4 strike
just a really really strong piece if
there's a best piece in the white
position I'd vote my knight on d3
without question
so they're repositioning preparing this
stuff and this is it's typical to want
to go for this but I have the reply f5
and this is the correct reaction to the
f5 break doing something other than f5
they have the ID idea to just lock this
down further and then it's black who has
some serious space this pawn with some
great depth here on the kingside and
play will start to drift over here you
know very King's Indian like and Kings
Indian defense like position for black
playing on the Kings side yeah even
though it has an advantage as White is
one that the computer isn't properly
evaluating I don't think it can
yeah so anyhow the short story here is
you have to you have to react to this f5
move with f4 make sure it does open up
on the Kings side takes and that's where
I guess it goes downhill it's suggesting
Bishop to c8 I think right around this
moment I was even suggesting Bishop to
c8 before playing f5 you know cuz he's
out of play now now that there is no
longer this pressure here I think black
can safely make one additional prep move
make one additional as odd as this may
sound developing move to move the bishop
back to his home square he's on its he's
underdeveloped unless there's some
tactic against d5 and I don't foresee
that I considered the bishop is
undeveloped on b7 so he should probably
go to c8 before welcoming these pawn
exchanges on the Kings side make one
additional prep move as it takes and it
likes c8 so it's a little bit late I
mean it's only half on advantage here
but yeah to make the the less committal
move first just what is maybe one way to
kind of view things they want F 5 F for
its opening up now and well
does like Bishop g4 happy about that
came there yeah so this is just a win
here huh plus two and a half doesn't
like f5 best I considered Bishop e6 but
I thought that this was good let's see
what that a winning continuation was
okay so it's citing other options as
well to take on e5 but pushing is fine
as well hmm oh oh oh oh here's the
difference if I'm taking on this square
if forces first Queen takes Bishop and
then I get that desired fork on g6 the
thing I was thinking about before when I
had that fork in mind yeah I thought
that the I thought that the Queen had to
take but by taking on f6 first the
knight gets to recapture when I do
capture on this square the root can be
recapturing although okay this is still
winning from this position after a
knight takes on f6 so mister multiple
tactics and this in this position here
where I have that discovered check if I
take here first yeah I kind of
discounted taking annunciate first
because I didn't like that this Knight
was here oh I could just safely keep my
bishop and yeah he's hit and when he
moves I'm taking here next okay yeah
okay a lot a lot of tactics missed their
take on f6 here and it likes taking on
this square first huh this is
I know rook takes and it does want to
just take on e5 and that throws away the
advantage and they tell for this is what
I had in mind on Queen takes well I
could even still take here that's not
working okay I get the exchange but it's
not as convincing what was my concern
what's taking here my concern was that
on this night here they could take here
first but I guess this is still quite
all right huh oh because at the end that
night is tricky man there's just Forks
everywhere has too fixated on forking
the rooks but simply landing on g6 and
then threatening to get into e 7 with
another Fork of the queen and king
mm-hm wish I had more time to consider
that position mm-hmm okay
missed missed tactical tricks I get my
knight into a nice square but they
eliminate it Queen here wants to keep
the Queen's on the board I don't know
what I would have oh that's what I would
have had yeah I didn't see this trick I
could take the knight if they take my e
pawn bishops pinned take the rook mm-hmm
Queen they're suppose they do something
like this though okay so I start prying
open like this takes okay I could go
here right away okay yeah I guess I
could mix it up a little bit and while
black is concerned about regaining that
pawn I could focus my attention a little
bit more over here on the gh files and
make use of my really strong Queen
physician who was really hitting a lot
of stuff is she not a lot of pieces are
observed here indirect defense mm-hmm
okay well I guess this is where it's
going to change then yeah so there are
no more tricks and it's back to even and
where was it that black had an advantage
that night was real a real pest didn't
like age five
this was my long-winded idea here
transfer my king over to the to the to
the defense of the B pawn takes rook
there does not like because of Bishop
here right now they did that just a
little bit later yeah they could have
done that right now and kicked my rook
off of this rank and then grabbed the
b-pawn so Bishop here right now and then
take here is a much different story okay
knight c6 instead and yeah this is this
is tough to play I feel like it's easier
for black to play in a way I do have
some open files I don't know if this was
such a good idea by black to play g4
because it is opening up more files
always of course the concrete idea is to
consider you know I believe that this
was the idea they had in mind which was
to defend or kick the rook off of the up
three square chase away the defender of
B 3 but yeah if they aren't really
crashing through on b3 they could have
but uh let me show it let me show about
here Bishop here and if I do this I
thought the idea would have been to push
and it still is an idea here here yikes
and Bishop back and now he's how'd he
defend that guy ooh okay
night there and where does it turn okay
I go after the a pond and I think now
it's going to be a win for white after a
blacks next move yeah that's pretty
significant advantage it's black who has
a difficult defense now and coping with
this past a pond hmm it really should
have never gotten to this point when I
had that open diagonal and they played
that g5 move I didn't see the clearly I
didn't see the correct knock out they're
the cleanest road to victory nor did I
even consider anything with that queen
of g6 moving seeing this tactic of rook
takes on f6 and that would have been a
nice finish going straight in for just
Knight takes here I should have
considered more these uh these
possibilities then my knight may be
jumping in here it's even pointing out
cleaning at g6 at this point some of my
okay I'm glad I just pointed this out
some of my concern was a knight on this
square being stranded I didn't get to
voice it during the game but I kind of
felt a little bit uncomfortable in a way
having my knight on this square where he
doesn't have support or I should say he
has support but support by a queen
instead of support with a very
convenient defender upon so I'm
restricted in some sense if my knight is
like this I don't know if this was the
exact well yeah I think this might have
been the the one variation I quickly
thought about takes here and then my
idea was to move the knight again but
the computer points out this idea of
queen of g6 with then rook takes Knight
my knight also has this Square to maybe
jump to okay
this was a interesting game again a
positional positional ID in mind with
these SC 4 a 4 moves in reply to this
Benko the pseudo pinko stuff here with
the B 5 I like this
positional stuff with the a 4 and C 4
and then that Queen sides lock down and
play turns as we saw on the kingside and
the big moment here is to know how to
correctly reply to that f5 move need to
get an F for open up the Kings side
where you have the better positioned
pieces okay well as usual feel free to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and as usual I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now
take care
you